dans un communiqué la cgt dévoile que la
direction de psa a proposé hier aux
organisations syndicales du site de
vesoul un accord local qui prévoit
d'augmenter le temps de travail effectif
de 7,8 pour cent soit de passer de 35
heures par semaine à 37 heures 45
une augmentation de 2,8 pour cent les
salaires et la suppression automatique
de 150 emplois par an d'ici 2020 pour la
cgt c'est une remise en cause pure et
simple des 35 heures est une dangereuse
portes ouvertes pour nous la cgt d'abord
inacceptable mais c'est quelque chose de
très dangereux ça veut dire que si la
direction arrive à trouver des syndicats
qu'ils mettraient leur signature au bas
de cet accord non seulement face face à
pourrait passer à vesoul si les salariés
ne se mobilise pas mais ça pourrait être
étendue à d'autres usines du groupe
sinon la totalité des usines du groupe
en france et c'est tout à fait
inacceptable
on ne on ne mettra jamais notre
signature au bas d'un accord qui remet
en cause les 35 heures un accord qui
pourrait aboutir d'ici la fin du mois de
juin
pour l'heure la direction du site de
vesoul qui emploie 3000 personnes n'a
pas souhaité réagir
mais du côté du groupe l'objectif
clairement affiché est d'assurer
l'avenir du site
dans un environnement particulièrement
concurrentiel